arbois petite cité de caractère du jura
ou vins et gastronomie attire chaque
année de nombreux touristes en ce mois
de juillet les terrasses sont bondées
sauf celle des ducks et du peak 6 des
cas kovy ddca contacts parmi la
vingtaine de salariés ont obligé les
patrons à fermer alors pour continuer à
travailler ils ont installé ce on
s'est dit qu'il fallait quand même faire
quelque chose pour garder une activité
dès qu'on passe une saison extrêmement
compliquée avec avec le collier des
tours et donc l'idée a germé en soirée
puis on a mis ça en place l'an demain
soir on est sur des cuisines différentes
juste qu'on arrive à associer nos de nos
deux cuisines en fête en une c'est les
deux quelle pixies voilà c'est une
association et qui fonctionne bien pour
faciliter l'installation
le camion est prêté par un ami madame la
maire a cédé pour quelques jours cet
emplacement et le bar d'à côté prête
gracieusement sa terre il ya pas de
concurrence
arbois au contraire on trouve que ça
fonctionne mieux
al'inverse et c'est évident dans la tête
de chacun des gérants donc voilà c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne
une solidarité qui ne surprend personne
ce qui est intéressant c'est ça c'est
qu'on va penser qu'à soi mais on est
dans un moment où en plus on voit bien
la différence entre les gens qui qui
sont soit individualistes ou qui font de
la collectivité moi je trouve ça très
bien c'est une super bonne idée pour la
ville d'arbois
ça amène du monde
et puis le fait que
je pour manger un coup à boire un coup
en même temps là ce sont le foot rock de
marque et romaric restera au pied de
l'église saint-just au moins jusqu'à la
fin de la semaine prochaine le temps que
leurs employés recouvre la santé